[Música]
y
colombia registró en el segundo
trimestre la mayor caída en la historia
de su economía un desplome del 15 7% que
contrasta con el segundo trimestre del
2019 cuando el país creció un 3,1 por
ciento para el departamento
administrativo nacional de estadística
la caída de tres actividades económicas
explicarían el hundimiento del pib 1 es
el sector del comercio reparación
transporte alojamiento y servicios de
comida otros el de la construcción y el
tercero sería el de las industrias
manufactureras estos datos llegan cuando
el gobierno se prepara para la
reapertura en septiembre con el regreso
de la actividad aérea de la restauración
al aire libre o el último anuncio el de
cines y teatros esto en un momento en el
que se superan los 10.000 casos diarios
y los fallecidos se sitúan alrededor de
los 300 cada día sin embargo la
necesidad aprieta y en la última semana
se han sucedido protestas de colectivos
como el retail para reactivar la
economía o de los domiciliarios para
exigir mejores derechos laborales
[Música]
con un desplome del 95 en el segundo
trimestre del año el producto interior
bruto anual de eeuu recoge su peor golpe
con una caída de casi el 33% no se veían
estas cifras en los 80 años que se
recogen los datos oficiales y por
supuesto corresponden a las muchas
semanas que los estadounidenses han
estado encerrados en sus casas para
evitar la propagación del cob y 19 para
encontrar datos similares en eeuu
tendríamos que remontarnos a la gran
depresión oa la movilización tras la
segunda guerra mundial y es que caen los
componentes del producto interior bruto
ha habido un considerable descenso del
gasto de los hogares de la inversión de
las empresas y los expertos temen que la
situación pueda ir a peor porque
continúan aumentando los casos en varios
estados del país esto ha dado lugar a
que se vuelvan a cerrar algunas empresas
por lo que podrían darse peores datos en
el futuro
[Música]
la economía europea se hunde según las
últimas cifras presentadas por eurostat
el producto interior bruto de la unión
europea cayó un 11 7% en el segundo
trimestre de 2020 las peores cifras que
se recuerdan desde que comenzase a
publicarse este informe en 1995 y los
países cuyas economías han sufrido más
son también los que se han visto más
afectados por la pandemia como es el
caso de españa francia italia y bélgica
pero también la de aquellos que dependen
en gran medida del turismo como es el
caso de portugal además de algunos
países del este como hungría bulgaria o
rumanía han visto una contracción de la
economía que no se recordaba desde antes
de la caída del comunismo hace ahora 30
años y estas cifras no hacen sino
confirmar las previsiones de la comisión
europea que auguraba una contracción de
la economía de un 8,3 por ciento en 2020
las previsiones para 2021 eso sí son
mucho más optimistas pero se basaban en
la hipótesis de una vuelta progresiva en
la normalidad las olas de contagios que
hemos visto en las últimas semanas y la
posibilidad de una vuelta al
confinamiento poner en serio riesgo la
recuperación económica en europa
[Música]